hey guys I'm Irish art welcome to toilet
talk where I take you out of the kitchen
and into the bathroom to help you
properly bake brownies our question
today comes from my friend Carol okay
dear Addie I've been feeling really
bloated have been breaking out in
pimples and I've gained some weight
after giving birth last year my friend
told me that the best cure for all of my
problems is a colonic
I found a clinic nearby charging over
$100 Oh interesting choice of words so I
wanted to know if it's worth it or not
signed colon concerned Carol well Carol
I'm really glad that you reached out so
colonics also known as colon irrigation
or colon hydrotherapy have become really
popular as of late thanks to people like
Kim Kardashian or or gwyneth paltrow
touting the benefits so according to
proponents colonics flush out
accumulated fecal sludge that gets into
your colon walls that apparently can
cause blockages and prevent us from
flushing out or detoxing our body
naturally they basically flush 60 liters
of water through our [ __ ] and it's
kind of like an enema but way more
aggressive colonic clinic suggests that
colon irrigation can solve a whole range
of digestive issues like constipation
diarrhea IBS bloating but they also say
that it can help to prevent non
digestive problems like headaches skin
issues allergies depression and yes of
course weight loss while I haven't been
able to find any credible research to
suggest that colonics help with any of
these problems I'm actually concerned
about way more than you just wasting
your hard-earned money in fact experts
believe that Quantic scum with some
serious risk first fluid and electrolyte
imbalance when we flush 60 liters of
water through our rectum we end up
disrupting the very delicate fluid and
electrolyte balance in our gut so
electrolytes like sodium potassium
phosphate magnesium chloride and
bicarbonate can easily get drowned out
and we can end up with problems like
renal failure heart failure liver
failure and digestive issues I mean our
bodies have been doing this cleansing
thing for a long time don't mess it up
you also may flush away really important
new things
so consider yourself at a wave pool
you're the nutrients trying to get to
the intestinal wall to get absorbed ak8
the other side of the pool when all of a
sudden a big gush of water making a wave
flushes you back and pulled you away I
mean this kind of serious implications
for your body's ability to actually
absorb and utilize all those nutrients
that you've got from food number two
let's talk bacteria so we recently
talked about the importance of
probiotics in this video right here
check it out so when we flush out our
gut
we actually alter the important
bacterial environment as well as our
immune system and that can actually
cause digestive problems number three
let's go in on those digestive issues so
one series of case studies found that
people who underwent colon cleanses
actually experienced a wide range of
digestive issues like abdominal pain
cramping electrolyte imbalance and renal
failure they also found that people who
had pre-existing digestive issues like
IBS diverticulitis or Crohn's had even
higher risk of worsening their condition
sort of my biggest concerns is with
regards to regulation unlike registered
dietitians colonic clinics are not
regulated so anyone can just set up a
practice and flush away in Canada Health
Canada does regulate the equipment but
the practitioners not so much so if
you're not going to someone really
credible who knows what they're doing
you could end up with a serious
infection after losing weight sorry
Carol but this is nothing new or novel
people have been using enemas and
supplements and laxatives for years just
trying to lose a quick pound
unfortunately this is not actually fat
you're going to be losing it's just a
little bit of stool weight and some
water sustainable weight loss solutions
take real weight loss changes and
they're not filling that to just be
accomplished in an hour in a clinic well
Carol I hope that answered your
questions
if it did be sure to give it the thumbs
up guys leave me a message below with
what you guys
know what burning bowel question
[Music]